I don't envy my own tanglewood students
now coming from a very different world
where almost anything any note they put
down is right because having had to go
through a time where the criteria were
clear I think does train 10 in a way
that can be useful so I think what I
recognize people have asked me why there
are a lot of composers born in 1938
who've done good music and I think the
answer would be that we all went through
hell we were in a kind of a boot camp
together and in feeling like we needed
to survive that and reorganize it we
became quite strong if they are young
it's that they are expected to or
perhaps driven to assimilate so many
possibilities that the excitement of
limitation or the focus of limitation is
very hard for them to find because now
of course communication is so vast that
any music in the world is available
instantly and there are so many cultures
that do interesting things there's about
900 categories of pop music that we see
her ear at the Grammys all of that is
very difficult to file down and shape
into something very prospectus and
powerful that is not all those things
but is a selection I think that's for
I'm very grateful that I'm not starting
out now
and what I try to do with the people I
work with that are starting out because
I try to impress upon them that every
talented composer will write one good
piece but writing a lot means a broad
and very substantial base which is wide
and doesn't top